- [Voiceover] What I'm hoping
to explore in this video
is the notion of a sample space.
And it's a pretty, hopefully you'll find,
straightforward idea.
If you're doing a trial,
something that is probabilistic,
a trial or an experiment,
a sample space is just the
set of the possible outcomes.
So a very simple trial
might be a coin flip.
So if you're talking about a coin flip,
well then the sample space is going to be
the set of all the possible outcomes.
So you could get a heads
or you could get a tails.
That right over here is the sample space
for the coin flip.
And it's very useful because,
for example, if these are
equally likely outcomes
and you say well what's the probability
of the event of a heads, you say
okay that's one out of the
two equally likely outcomes.
Or you could even construct, once you know
all of the possible outcomes even if
they aren't equally likely, you could say
well let's create a
probability distribution.
We at least know what the sample space is.
We know what the possible outcomes are,
now let's think about the probability
of each of those outcomes.
But a lot of times when people
talk about sample spaces,
they're often, they tend to
be most useful, I would say,
when you have equally likely outcomes
like in the case of a fair coin flip.
Because then from the sample space,
it's fairly straight forward
to think about the probability
of various events.
But this is a simple sample
space right over here,
but let's make things a
little bit more interesting.
Let's imagine a world,
so let's just put this aside a little bit.
Let's imagine a world
where there's a bakery
and at that bakery there are three types,
three flavors of cupcakes,
but there's also three
different sizes of cupcakes.
So now we're essentially
looking at two different ways
in which the thing that we're
going to be sampling can vary.
So what we're doing,
let me write this down.
So we have our flavors,
flavors of cupcakes at this bakery.
And let's say that you have chocolate,
chocolate,
you have, let's say there's strawberry,
strawberry,
and let's say that there is vanilla,
there is vanilla.
And they come in three different sizes.
So sizes.
Sizes could be small,
I'll just write it out, small,
medium,
or large.
So if you were, and let's
say each of these flavors
come in each of these sizes.
Or you could view it the other way around,
each of these sizes come
in all three flavors.
So now how do you
construct the sample space?
If you were to say, look I'm gonna go,
you know, I'm gonna blindfold myself
and walk into this bakery and randomly
somehow pickup a cupcake and my fingers
can't tell the flavor or
the size of the cupcake,
what are the possible,
what are the possible
outcomes for the cupcake I'll pick?
And the outcome would be both the flavor
and the size of the cupcake.
Well there's a bunch of
ways to think about this.
One way is you could draw a tree.
You could say, okay well I'm gonna pick
three different flavors.
I could either pick chocolate,
chocolate,
I'm gonna pick strawberry,
strawberry,
or I'm going to pick vanilla,
vanilla.
And then for each of those flavors,
I'm only gonna pick a
small, medium, or large.
So you could say small,
medium, large.
Small, so this is a small chocolate,
this is a medium chocolate,
this is a large chocolate.
This is a small strawberry,
medium strawberry,
large strawberry.
This is a small vanilla, medium vanilla,
large vanilla.
And so you see there's
nine possible outcomes.
Once again, this is a medium chocolate.
You picked a chocolate
and it was a medium one.
This is a large vanilla.
You picked a vanilla,
and it is a large one.
And you could have done
it the other way around.
You could have said, well okay,
I'm going to either pick a small,
medium, or large
and then for each of those I'm gonna pick
either a chocolate,
strawberry, or vanilla.
And I'll just use the first letters.
So I'm either gonna pick a chocolate,
a strawberry, or a vanilla.
When I write the S over
here in this magenta color,
I'm talking about the flavor
and if I write the S in green,
I'm talking about small.
So here you can have, if
you have a medium cupcake,
it could be chocolate,
it could be strawberry,
or it could be vanilla.
If you have a large cupcake
it could be chocolate,
strawberry,
or vanilla.
So for example, this was a
medium, chocolate cupcake.
Over here a medium, chocolate
cupcake is this one.
It's medium, chocolate.
It would be that one over here.
So you could use these
kind of a tree diagram like this
to think about the sample space,
to think about the nine
possible outcomes here.
But you could also,
you could also do a,
I guess you could say grid,
where you could write
the flavors, so you could have chocolate,
chocolate,
actually, let me just write the,
well no, let me write them out.
Actually, let me just,
let me just write the letters since this
is gonna take a long time to do.
So you could have the flavors chocolate,
strawberry, vanilla.
So that's along that axis.
And then you have your sizes.
You can have a small,
a medium,
or large.
And you can set up a grid here.
So this is another way to do it.
And notice this grid has nine boxes.
So let's look at it.
So set up the grid.
Set up the grid.
And so what is this one going to be?
This is a small chocolate.
Small.
Small chocolate.
What is this one?
This is going to be a small,
a small strawberry,
A small strawberry.
And you could just keep
constructing like this
where everything in this row,
there are all about small.
Oops.
Do it in the...
This is small.
I'm having trouble changing colors.
Alright (laughing).
There is a small and then this is a small,
this is a small vanilla.
This color changing is really,
it's a difficult thing.
Small vanilla.
And all of these, these are all,
this would be a medium chocolate.
Medium strawberry.
Medium vanilla.
Large chocolate, large strawberry,
large vanilla.
And once again you have nine outcomes.
This is another way to think about
all of the possible outcomes when
you're looking at these two ways
in which my cupcakes could vary.
Another way, a third way
that you could do it,
is you could literally
just construct a table.
Well you could say, okay
I could have a chocolate,
actually I'm going to
use the letters again.
So let's say we make,
this is the flavor column.
And then this is the size column.
Size column.
And so you could say
I could have a chocolate that is,
so let's see, there's
three types of chocolate
that I could have.
And they could be
they could be small, medium, or large.
You could say there's three types of,
three types of strawberry.
It could be small, medium, or large.
So let me write that in.
Small, medium, large.
Or you could say oh, there's
three types of vanilla.
There's three types of,
I'm color changing again.
Three types of vanilla.
Once again, it could be
small, medium, or large.
So you have these nine possibilities.
Now, sample space,
the sample space isn't telling you
if they're equally likely or not.
It's just telling you, hey, if
you're gonna do an experiment,
what are all the different possibilities,
the possible outcomes for that experiment?
Now in the case where
they are equally likely,
it can be very, very
useful because you can say
you could do something like, if you said
okay, it's equally likely to pick any one
of these nine outcomes, you could say
well what's the probability of,
what's the probability of
getting something that is
either small or chocolate?
And so you could see well
how many of those events
out of the total actually
meet that constraint?
But we'll do more of
that in future videos.
That's just a little bit of a clue
of why we even care about things
like sample spaces.
Especially sample spaces like this,
where we're looking along two ways
or multiple ways that something can vary.
And these types of sample
spaces in particular
are called compound sample spaces.
So these right over here,
this is a compound sample space,
because we're looking
at two different ways
that it can vary.
Not just a heads or tails,
it can vary by size or by flavor.
And you can even have compound
sample spaces that vary
in more than two ways.